So relative minimum is a value of the function that is lower than other values
of the function, but just values that are near that point. So, this is why the
point "D" on this function over here is a relative minimum since we know that
the range of this graph goes all the way down to negative infinity D Is
definitely not the lowest point on the graph. In fact we can see, looking at
points over here. To the left hand side of the graph. That there are values
visible to us right now. That are lower than the value of the function at D.
However, compared to all the values adjacent to D. Whether you move to the left
or to the right, the function has its lowest value at this spot. This is
different from a global maximum like at G. There's no other point on this
parabola where the function has a lower value than it does at G.